a lot of times in dating you're going to
experience people that are hot and cold
right one week they're texting you like
crazy the next week they're being short
with you and they're not giving you so
much attention what's our first
emotional response to that it's called
them out right say Hey listen I don't
understand why you're not hitting me up
or Hey listen I think I need to take a
step back from this situation because
it's really bothering me let me tell you
something the worst thing that you can
do is verbally tell someone that their
lack of attention grilling hot tubs even
if it really helps telling them gives
them all the power the reality is even
if you're feeling that way you need to
take actions and stay silent you can't
say [ __ ] to them and now what he says
there is uh basically if you think
there's an issue don't talk about it
just remain silent and hope that it
works itself out and the thing is as a
man I can I can sort of understand that
instinctively like I do apply that
sometimes to relationships when I
shouldn't I apply it to uh like
household repair issues something's
broken my wife says can you fix it I'll
say just leave it it'll it'll work
itself out but in reality that's not
actually what you should do